[Music]
welcome to this week's winners honor
Wednesday we have Lee Barbra on the show
and Lee's got experience with bita let's
hmos renter and serviced accommodation
we're only the full works so he's gonna
give you the up the down share his story
and give you some pearls of wisdom so
Lee welcome to wins on a Wednesday oh
great to have you on the show a feeling
good so when we met a year ago yeah
you're in a situation whereby you have
this real hunger and desire to get your
hands dirty try out different property
strategies Oh
you've now got your hands dirty you've
got experience a lot of different
property avenues so what have you
learned I think Judy Liggins that was
something that I definitely didn't get
first but I know now there's so
important yes about that due diligence
yeah but before you go into anything so
what do you mean what do you mean why do
you diligence what does that mean just
it might be checking out the area you
know middlesboro for example a guy hmm
Ellensburg and I thought I knew
Middlesboro of course that was a long
time ago yeah things have changed now I
mean I never did I never heard of thumbs
we was at university but now is the dumb
thing everybody's get out and sweet so
it's very difficult to get tenants
unless you've got forearms weeds
everywhere because you've got a rent to
rent in Middlesbrough yeah which is a
HMO and how's he doing it's doing okay
it's not okay yeah right I've got
the copper professionals in there I was
told to get professionals by is a
Katrina Katrina Jones yep
seminar really resonated with me as well
in a way that you know it showed you how
to do it exactly and what she's done and
how much she's making from it yeah and
you've been he's been surrounded with
all these property experts and trainers
because you're on the Academy so you've
met a lot actually Katrina Lesley
Alastair myself Russell Trevor and
you've literally been like a sponge for
the last year yeah which is fantastic so
what's really cool you recently got a
serviced accommodation property in
Liverpool
yes that's what happened yesterday
yesterday I mean I thought all my
Christmases came at once because I got
you know we got booked income through my
phone beeps all the time telling me
there's a booking come through oh yeah
what's that I look at it might be suited
for nice something that's nice but this
one was 29 and maps which meant how much
money did you get paid yesterday Iraq
that was down for five grand
now this is the ups and down side of it
because a little later come through is
the cancellation the council was
cancelled it is my missus whole part of
having a team involved with it they came
through and said no the credit card is
broad you know because it's probably and
obviously we don't touch that so of
course they could be in after a month
and then I'm not gonna pay for it so yes
so we don't want that
yeah but you luckily you've got the
experience to know the difference
between a good guest and a bad guest and
things like that now yeah thanks this
diner yeah
who's obviously yourself Robert
Kiyosaki's book yeah we've got poured
out of course is where everybody starts
off yeah we're the short stuff
the whole thing of good and bad debt was
alien to me at the time but I learned
that and that prompted me to go into
your crash pit
what was it that made you get into
property what was your strongest reason
why I think mainly because he you just
need something you need that stability
their support background in the about
know you know it's I I lost my mom
unfortunately and that was does very sad
but what my mom taught me she was at she
was in see property but on a working
basis and what she what she got was too
bad you know the only one bad one
bathroom Terrace towers now what I did
teach me is the through inflation the
you know it the growth of that prophecy
just an open open open oh yeah so the
fat mom cheese is quite big for that at
the moment now it's it's pretty much the
same for everywhere you see shot you
crash cause you know you know you have
the depression and expansion on the side
and from Manchester especially it seems
to have a lot of expansion yeah so more
slide Birmingham most like London yeah
it could have a crash you some part but
a minute is still expanding yeah so
basically then so you saw your mom how
much money she made by mistake just in
competitions you know yeah I just felt
that when I bought it so how much how
much money and she made in the property
I think it was she bought it for
about program for grant so it's worth
roundabout 130 by now
Wow it's just it's just ridiculous
expansion yeah and then of course you're
getting paid in your rents yeah so you
want instability tell us a bit about
your sort of personal life that are in
your your your personal life personally
I think me and my fiance we wanted to
get married in a castle in Durham so
that felt we wanted to get married in
the more intimate wedding so we then say
okay we're really a little bit silly so
we're gonna get married in it so you
probably this year we don't know you
know that that's very much on the couch
now but you know we're my personal life
and things like that you know what love
life would be like one of the things
that I remember we spoke about when you
first came to the crash course yeah and
we got I know you just bought a property
off plan yes and that was that still
hasn't completed a year later which is
very disappointing very I mean what do
you learn from that
hey well I always do about outside use
always a risk yeah so that's why it
literally update architect form so
there's a number of things that can get
away about but what it does mean again
why when you say to your you know crash
course whereas you get the expansion
from that so they grow from that where
what Balti think it was only put 25
grand down okay
so I mean that was in Liverpool as well
so Liverpool growth is 7.2 yeah so that
was three years ago
so 7.2 time 3 and you can see how that
yeah grow yeah no everything's been rosy
with your property journey
you've got properties that have taken a
very long time to complete you've had
properties that aren't full and things
like that
why have you learned from some of the
struggles within property what I've been
the key lessons you've learned from that
definitely due diligence yeah you
mentioned that yeah do diligence
checking out the area so an area that I
thought I knew there was Middlesboro
which is where I went to university so
you went to university to do that area
pretty well yeah and but the thing is
though you say due diligence UNT you
went to university there have you lost
money in Middlesboro and overall maybe
I'm a bit yeah yeah because you know
I've got enough tenants in there to pay
though I'm not but still bills to be
paid so yeah
the loss is fairly minimal yeah so it's
kind of breaking even small okay I mean
in property if you do it completely
wrong you can lose a lot of money you
can also make a lot of money
I guess breaking even either you know
learn from that it's not it's not the
world borderline but then you've also
got some deals that are very successful
and you're making good profit on as well
yes so overall it's a win are you still
working no well yes there yeah what why
do you still choose to work because my
job is is quite exciting job for a lot
of people yeah you know beat it so easy
this job is in video games okay I make
video games yeah I mean a lot of people
say oh yeah video games that's what
everybody wants to do is it's great but
yeah but I've been doing it now round
around 15 maybe 17 years yeah could you
[ __ ] what would happen if you lost your
job now I would plant deals you beyond
yeah cuz you've got you've got
properties you're making an income
because
that was something long we spoke and
you've also you don't want me talking
about your about your condition as well
yeah I think I like him later because
when we first met I was okay
yeah but because it's a does it does
progress you know so it gets to that
point where you can't ID anymore watch
this just so people know what we're
talking about this is multiple services
yeah
I was diagnosed in multiple sclerosis in
2014
I've been said that probably this is
from the hospital by the way hospitals
that have probably had it Simba first
symptom which is around about 2001 2002
so that's nearly 18 years ago are
probably 18 years ago but he just didn't
know well no no you see that in 14 I
suspected it
yeah but it's 2014 where they said no
you definitely go how does it affect
your everyday life oh very I mean for a
while I'd say a good ten years
didn't really affect me it's not we get
on with it I was doing combat sports
think it really didn't I was running
everywhere like I really the day I'd go
running around the park no problem mm
you know when it came to investment
property yeah I'll tell ya it wasn't a
big problem course it progresses so at
that point it does get to a problem
where it was getting away a little bit
so you have to make adjustments yeah the
thing is though how are you I'm 39 today
no you're not
yeah it's your birthday Yes Mother dude
happy birthday so so when I got either
Prosecco and champagne that we think it
was also yes that's incredible I didn't
know it was your birthday today but
Courtney did say give him some Prosecco
oh happy birthday I mean the fact that
you're 39 I mean you've got you've got
MS you know you do struggle to get
around you have up you have a stick and
stuff and it is progressing to get to
get worse I started using that I'd say
six months okay it's not a safe one but
the thing is though you you don't you
don't talk about it you don't let it
stop you it's not a big deal let's be
honest is that for many people it would
be for many people you know they'd be at
home they'd be saying oh you know it's a
bit terrible you know they'd be using it
as an excuse not so I can come out and
view properties no I can't get up and
about very easily but that is not the
case for you know I never hear you talk
about it no but it is as far as the
doctors are concerned it is a big deal
they would say yes why did why does that
not stop you still continuing to get
deals go around the country and how does
it how does that not get in the way you
just can't let it it is tube mindset I
even wanted to do this and you don't
it's as simple as that
so mindset is to push yourself yeah
that's what I've done since day one yeah
because I think there's a lot of people
you know that have physical problems
mental problems and it's it's really
hard so hopefully you know rather than
it I mean certainly well I broke my leg
you know I actually feel that inspired
people you know you can you can flip the
cards and turn submit button to a good
and that's what I'm so glad you're able
to inspire people yeah you know yeah
definitely is something that you said
and when you did have the accident I
think it was you know what was it about
and say this to me self nearly every day
you go and I'm just gonna blank cuz it's
your birthday what you said that inspire
you went on break my leg kind of because
you saw your video where the hospital
was pretty rendus boho you you you hire
the caring by the way yeah boy morphine
on now here is your mindset they told
you so you carry on and help others yeah
so and it's very much like that with me
how can I help with this it's not just
about me you know I've got a little dog
now so you know it's not just about me
and my wealth and think about ice
family's wealth you know it's he's
building that so it pushes me more yeah
but it does msl know it's irrelevant
yeah I saw people one of your seminars
in a wheelchair and it didn't stop them
yeah why should it that's great
so what are your plans then for this for
this next coming year
I think expand on the essays you have a
very lucrative and you know we're really
exciting to begin and when year when you
do it right you can just leave it yeah
you can automate it in a way that
systemized if you like and just work
like quite work so it is a very scary
element a lot of people like essays
hotels think I'm not ready for that I
would like that just out when it's like
hate your moles no not really but I yeah
I've just got a thing all that gonna
bother with h'mong yeah I did yeah
after being on your course how to do it
I did what's been your biggest con of
successes or victory moments over the
last 12 months I'd say when you read
further hmm that's quite exciting you
can say I did that
yeah you can put your stamp on something
yeah and say I did that and this is
where I don't work
yeah this is quite cool it's quite
satisfying isn't it when yeah
turn a house into a home happy tenants
happy guests yeah
turning like a wreck into someone that
looks really awful and it's the same
with essays as well yeah and it's like
taking that I mean the essays we go is
run Surin who runs her own essay and is
pretty much a blank canvas a brand new
blank canvas yeah you know again
systemization with it brings somebody
and get the armor get the bedding in
things like that the even the cutlery in
the drawers you can get somebody else to
do that so these people that are worried
with a condition right now they say that
they're worried about the future or
wherever it be these ways of doing it
without really doing anything you can
get all the people to do it or you
systemized it yeah I make it work I was
gonna host I was gonna say you love your
job so you're working full time as a
long side doing the property stuff
you've got MS you've got a little dog
and feelings I was gonna ask you about
systemization how do you systemize the
property business give us some give us
some tips bill on the phone mostly yeah
I mean my fiance's constantly good to be
a puppy in a corner phone whether it be
looking at spare room calm yeah you know
something like roommate oh you know oh
now is two key you know booking you know
it's that that's what's going out do you
pretty much feel like you run your
business from your phone pretty much how
is that how does that work well yeah
just you can get apps on your phone that
will run it boy yeah you just have to
manage it yeah so you know you say okay
right we've got we've got a guest coming
in and me in the SATs um Friday right
okay
sound cleaner so the cleaner knows about
it whether they check
they're checking out on Monday so the
cleaner knows then to go in I round
about two o'clock on a Monday or 11
o'clock wherever she wants today and
clean it he's ready for the next gift so
if I saw hotel I don't know but it
doesn't feel like I'm running a hotel
you know I can do it from a pole
one of the interesting things about
about you Leigh is most of my students
they'll do a deal and they just want to
talk about the money set up so I made
this much money or I just rented the
property out for this much this is how
much profit making and I'll talk about
the money which is fine because at the
end of the day a property business is
there to make money yeah but you never
talk about the money I know you make I
know you're making good money and I know
you've got that security now but you
only ever send me messages about things
like look at this wonderful review that
I got from one of my guests look at this
picture this beautiful cushion and
feature you always talk about how much
now you've added to others the bond of
it the joy of it why is that I don't
know I mean I will say I have done that
recently with the SAT because it does
look phenomenal has just got the review
and the acrid ation if you like of it as
exceptional on booking.com and when you
look at it yeah it is it must be a great
achievement yeah being locked is
exceptional on booking.com for your
property property was like 10 so the
reviews of again it's 10 out of 10 all
the time so the reason why it comes as
exceptional on booking.com is because it
keeps getting sent out some reviews now
by doing that and you look at the other
big hotels in Manchester for example the
Midland
a park or something like that yeah
so you're doing this I sense very much
you doing it for the love I think you
love property yeah I can do it like I
say I can do it from the phone I don't
have to do much but when people think of
property investors or property
entrepreneurs or landlords they think of
greedy money-grubbing old man smoking
cigars whereas you're the opposite of
that mold you're someone that really
cares you've got a big heart you add
value and then the money just follows
yeah I really do want to provide a good
service yeah I want to be a good lung
them yeah even if it's missing all that
okay is a problem with the shower that's
way fine
what's wrong with the hinges that got
the devil's power right okay but
especially centered satisfied are
getting sort for the company that makes
those changes get new energy they get
somebody else the contractor to go in
and fit them I'll say well half an hour
phone call phone calls very simple to do
yeah so an it provides I keep that going
descendants because it doesn't end up a
real bad yeah you know and they can just
carry things
how do you find how have you managed to
find your power team the single example
Power Team now I just get free
contractors yeah through VA all the
essays and everything like that again
through the agent my agent the agent
know just where these how do you know
that's the template of how you find your
parents okay you know all the people the
sources the contractors the agents the
you so you can do all from your phone
but how are you building this palliative
right okay well I do actually visit the
agents there's some agents that
suggested to me but then later on I
found that these really out working for
me yeah
so then I get up me bomb
I'll go and look at it yeah so we're
going to visit the area again we might
you know I look around look around see
the powers and things like that and the
interesting things that people might
want to go to an eventual ear about an
agent and say okay can can they take you
on sure after you the thing is a good
relationship yeah
it's better than anything absolutely and
when you you cannot have true passive
income without a good team I don't think
no so you've got sometimes you have to
do the work at first put the work in but
then once you've put the work in and
you've got off your bum and you've found
an agent you've found a team they can
then sort everything and that's when it
becomes truly passive what do you think
yes that way that passive side of it
you're very important especially to me
especially there's other people who've
got a similar condition yeah what would
your advice be to somebody who has got a
condition whether that's a mental
condition a physical condition an
illness setback but were wanting to do
property but wanting to buy and and sell
and be an entrepreneur but it was really
holding them back what advice or comfort
would you give them I would say never
hold you back because if you do that
you're gonna miss out you're gonna miss
out on it so why why would you let that
hold you down
it is something that physical mental
yeah fair enough
what can is there a way you can get
around it is that is there a way there
you can find something in you to push
you to do that yeah and eventually
you'll see success yeah that's great I
love that I guess you can always find a
reason why not so but successful people
despite the setback so people that try
and find a reason why why they can how
helpful is the training been that you've
been on with with it with ourselves yeah
thing with the training I think you go
to crash course you learn all this
Oh everything I want and it's a lot to
take in
you've got so much energy you're like
whoa you know when when you first meet
you
well technically have now actually met
you just against age and it's quite
overwhelming in a way but it's quite
excited at the same time yeah I thought
this guy is excited about what you're
doing and I want that excitement you
know and you will find a way to you know
to be that person yeah you know I think
if you you can make it successful you've
got I can do it yeah and you are doing
and have done that so that's fantastic
more late happy birthday and thank you
so much for coming down to be on the
show and I look forward to seeing you
continue to make money in property but
also add value to people's lives thank
you thanks mate
thank you so much for watching the video
that is the reason why I'm doing this
your success is my oxygen every single
week we've got people becoming
financially free if you'd like to see
more success students you can do that
right here but what I'd really suggest
is why don't you come and join us at the
property investors crash course come on
on my guest completely free and I'll
personally be there for two days to help
you get started you can see what happens
right here what you'll notice is all of
these stories they all start at the
crash course so come along my guests
can't wait to see you there
peace out